après quatre mois de détention dans la
prison de koléa à l'est d'alger khaled
rares eni va faire face à la justice
le journaliste directeur du site
d'informations en ligne casbah tribune
correspondant de la chaîne de télévision
française tv5 monde et de reporters sans
frontières est accusé d'incitation à un
attroupement mon armée et d' atteinte à
l'unité de la nation des chefs
d'inculpation grave mais totalement
infondées selon pierre autin le fils du
militant anti coloniale maurice audin
est l'auteur d'une tribune dans le
quotidien l'humanité qui dénoncent les
atteintes aux droits de la presse dans
le pays
l'algérie prétend participer au concert
des nations en signant des traités
internationaux qui garantissent les
droits et libertés dont la liberté de la
presse
elle doit se ressaisir libéré khaled
rares et nie tout simplement et laisser
les journalistes faire leur travail
laisser les citoyens s'expriment et tout
simplement
khaled rares eni est un précurseur dans
la couverture du l'irak
ce mouvement de contestation qui a
secoué le pays pendant plus d'un an à
partir de février 2019
un mouvement qui a précipité le départ
de l'ex président abdelaziz bouteflika
c'est d'ailleurs lors d'une
manifestation le 7 mars que le
journaliste est interpellé une première
fois il sera finalement emprisonné
vingt jours plus tard ébranlé par cette
affaire le pouvoir algérien réplique
lors d'une interview le 1er mai dernier
le chef de l'état adèle madjid tebboune
estime sans le citer que le jeune
reporter est un espion au service de
puissances étrangères
tandis que certains journalistes
commettent des erreurs par manque de
formation d'expérience et oeuvre à les
rectifier
d'autres comme est délibérément en
s'appuyant sur des puissances étrangères
quelqu'un qui vient d'être interrogé au
sujet d'une forte déclaration sur l'état
algérien et qui seront juste après dans
des ambassades étrangères afin d'en
rendre compte
j'assimile cela un travail d' espions
l'enjeu du procès qui s'ouvre
aujourd'hui est important pour aller
draguer ni selon la loi algérienne
il encourt jusqu'à dix ans de prison